Nvidia reached out to us and challenged us
to do something cool with their new mobile workstation laptops
So I reached out to Sam and challenged him to an art duel
He and I are gonna sit down each one of us with a laptop and see who can bust out the coolest render
But here's the catch
We are going to be on battery power only so you need to finish it in the time of one charge of a battery
Nothing else no mice. No keyboards
The winner of this contest gets to keep one of these laptops and the loser
Has to take the other person's wallpaper image and make it the background in their phone for at least one week
All right. Sam's waiting for me. Let's do this
*evil laughter*
*sword unsheathing sound*
So we're on battery power I got an hour and 15 minutes remaining
94% already. Oh my gosh
As you can see within our social distancing here not gonna lie feels pretty risky my wife Sarah
She advised me not to come today, but I did it anyway. Just for you guys.
Let's see what else we got in this asset pack Beluga Soros. Ooh a falling statue. I want to do that.
This cool freaking robot here. Not rigged. It's just a collection of random parts
So rigging is when you have like a skeleton in place and you can animate something to move.
A bio mutant.
Ooh, that sounds cool. Pizza Steve.
Hopefully, we don't pick Pizza Steve. But the thing is I haven't seen his 3D model yet, and if he's good -.
Alright! Pizza Steve! Let's see what you got!
OHHOHO
*Sam wheezes*
*Dramatic music*
Woah, Pizza Steve almost made me lose my mask.
Pizza Steve literally almost killed me.
He's not rigged.
*Niko wheezes*
So he's stuck in that pose forever. But why would you ever need to change anything about Pizza Steve?
So this is the challenge where we both have Pizza Steve and we're trying to make the-
We're trying to do Pizza Steve justice
First thing I gotta do is give Pizza Steve a makeover.
This cheese was like too yellow and I want to get it more of that like kina nice, luscious, white and orange, ya know?
Ya know what I'm sayin'?
Like that toasty- Toasty oven cheese.
He needs to have the meat sweats dripping off him.
You know when you pull out a fresh pie out of the oven that's got the meat sweats.
I'm at 77%.
Wow.
Oh boy, my battery. 77%. That's fast, but it's probably because I've got all this super high-tech rendering going on right now.
*Time-lapse music*
You know, it's been really rainy in LA during the whole pandemic here.
And it's really like suited the, the mood of the whole thing.
Like, it's kept, it's really kept people indoors, which is a good thing.
Well, it's definitely making my fingers nice and stiff.
Perfect!
It is hard to be fast on the trackpad.
This trackpad. It works pretty well as long as you make sure you bind the middle mouse button to something.
Cause it's a crucial button for Cinema 4D.
Without it, you can't move around in your viewport.
Beeple taught me these render challenges are all about figuring out your composition as early as possible.
Once you know where your cameras gonna be, and your framing,
you get to just worry about what you're gonna see and not what you're not gonna see
I'm gonna call this piece- I think "The Toppling of Papa John", "The Fall of the Papa", "The Fall of the Father."
*Both laugh*
I mean Pizza Steve is gonna be a recurring nightmare for him for the next year.
Sam's gonna have to replace that picture of his new baby with a picture of Pizza Steve throwing this man off a pedestal.
*Niko laughs*
Assuming the audience votes for my piece.
Once this video's up it's too late to vote.
But if you haven't followed our Instagram, you should go follow it.
It's @CorridorDigital.
You can help vote on things.
You can help us know what you're looking for.
The @corridordigital Instagram page go follow it.
I am at 66%. Oh man having this live viewer update all the time is really eating through the battery.
Sam, what are you at?
Aw, 68!
Oh, I'm not doing too bad. You know lighting is like what lets you hide what you are missing.
The lighting gives you a mood. It gives you shading. It gives you volume. Without light, you don't have emotion.
Feel like I'm working in slow motion right now.
Maybe it's because you've got those Matrix glasses on, and you're in bullet time.
Oh, man.
AH!
Ooh, it's heating up.
This pizza pie is in the oven
You can't take the heat of my pizza oven.
52%!
Oh, Jesus. 57%.
Why didn't you tell me that they were gonna die when we started actually using the computer for super-intensive rendering?
Actually, designed for creators, the Razorblade 15 Studio Edition was crafted to unlock workstation-class performance,
with the mobility of one of the most compact, 15-inch laptops in the world.
So I'm using you know the NVIDIA Quadro RTX 5000, which is a workstation GPU.
It has more memory than gaming GPUs do. So for things like uh- like octane here,
where everything's being rendered on the GPU, all your textures need to be stored on the GPU.
So this workstation GPU lets me have more high-resolution textures versus like a gaming GPU.
Remember when I was telling you about the temperature of my oven?
I'm setting the scene for Mr. Pizza-man's demise.
Pizza Steve "colon" Crust Rising
50 percent
Ooh Hoo
44 percent. I'm reaching the end here.
Save as...
*Niko laughs*
Oh my God!
I'm just not even saving my project file until the last second.
You been workin' on this-
The first- Before I even started working, I saved the file, and I'm like, this is the file I'm using.
I got bloom I got post-processing,
I got it all enabled in every freakin spot I possibly can, yet I'm not seeing it.
Why come my bloom no work?
WHY COME MY BLOOM NO WORKIN'?
Here, I'm gonna refresh my V-port.
AH- still not working.
*angry noise*
Do you have any - uh - thoughts on why I suck?
Oh, boy, I could write a whole book!
Oh, I'm wasting valuable time.
I have to reimport Pizza Steve.
There it is!
Oh, he's full of color and life. Dude, this is looking sick!
I am quite happy with this.
I'm glad. I'm glad he feels like he's a real hotshot today.
Seeing that finish line is the best.
I'm gonna like bust right through it.
And I guess I should render it, huh?
Alright, let's do it.
Here it goes...
*Niko clapping*
Uh, 39%. Just adding my final touches for my lighting.
Ooh, it's only 11%.
Changing settings. Oof, that cost me valuable time.
My battery is at 24%. 17 minutes left.
Whoo!
Alright.
I just wish my Bloom was working.
Second render. Here we go.
I guess doing this render, I can tell you a little bit about this computer.
NVIDIA also has something called NVIDIA Studio, where they basically work with all these different companies,
from Cinema 4D and Octane to Adobe to uh- Blackmagic Design,
to make sure that their software is accelerated by these cards.
That these cards are being leveraged to their maximum potential.
You're leveraging the power of the card for more than just playing video games.
Whether you're encoding video, or editing things in Premiere, or doing effects in After Effects,
lots of cool stuff you can do with a- a workstation card
like rendering this really high res render
I'm at 52 percent of the way there!
Render Version One.
Let's just make a render just in case my entire world collapses.
Assuming I didn't screw anything up, I can get it out
But if there's anything screwed up, then I'm in trouble.
*Niko laughs* So-
I'm getting so close. You can taste this slice
Ooh, this cleaned up real nice.
Aw yeah, this is pretty sweet.
28; Too low for comfort.
Come on!
*Niko claps*
Let's go, Gmail!
Come on, phone.
This is actually kinda concerning.
Why are you so slow right now?
I'm gonna stand up.
OH- That feels good.
So my resolutions jacked.
I'll take a photo of the screen like Clint did.
I should have used the mouse.
Let's go, Gmail!
*Niko claps rhythmically*
Finish that loading bar!
*More rhythmic clapping*
The battery is at 18 percent.
20 percent remaining
It's done!
14 percent remaining on the battery.
I did it.
I. Am. Done!
What did I end up with?
18%! Not bad.
We're gonna text them to each other, all right?
Okay.
All right. I'm ready. Are you ready?
All right ready!
Three, two, one, send.
*Niko laughs*
*Sam laughs*
*They both laugh*
Woahhhh
*Niko laughs more*
Woahhh
This looks actually really cool.
Oh, these are the mutant men.
*More laughter*
When pepperoni hot, he get sweaty? Or are they just tears?
It's pretty good.
I'm not gonna lie, I like your environment that you made, too.
Like there's metal grids, and a cool background.
Your camerawork just makes it way- Look way more intense than mine.
*Sam laughs*
It just- It's framed really nicely by my phone.
Sam did it on a laptop. On battery power.
The computer never slowed me down. The only slowness was in here.
*Niko laughs*
I should also mention that if you end up picking up an RTX studio laptop, you get three months of Adobe for free.
So, access to all their programs for three months.
To learn more about NVIDIA Studio and Razorblade Studio laptops, check out the links in the top of our description.
*transition sound effect*
Rollinggggg
All right, so Sam and I have stayed off of Instagram, and so we don't know who the winner is.
Christian, here, has the tally. But before we find out, we wanted to hear from a couple of different professionals here, as to their opinion.
We're joined by Clint, CG master,
Jake, creator of crazy ideas here at Corridor,
and Griffin, who is our art guy.
He is the professional who we must impress the most.
And the winner? They get the laptop.
*surprised noises*
They get the laptop?!
Yeah, one of those NVIDIA Creator Studio laptops.
Image one.
All right, here we go!
What?
Pepperoni hot, he get sweaty?
This is-
Just tears?
This is definitely Sam.
This is Sam.
*Niko laughing*
Uhm, the lighting is - is - is the first thing that I noticed, after the initial obvious stuff.
Which is um-
*Sam laughs*
The- The obvious stuff?
I just realized this is an oven.
Oh!!!
I just realized that's an oven, too. Wow, Sam. You are a misunderstood artist, man
This really speaks to the duality of the image cuz, you know,
he's standing there
like he's not afraid to die, doesn't have a care world.
But - uh - behind those sunglasses, there might actually be a whole world with pain. To me, that's art.
I like that. That's my honest statement. My artist's statement.
I'm also wondering is- Is crust hair, or is crust hat?
At the end of the day, the things that I appreciate technically, are that the material properties of everything in the image,
are consistent.
On a technical level, the two things that I have an issue with, that haven't been discussed so far,
are the sunglasses are, apparently totally opaque,
and made of a substance which absorbs all light.
Because there is absolutely no reflection, and um,
The letters in the second half of the sentence.
It is legible, but I find that the values between the yellow letters and the gray pan are a little too close,
and they tend to blend.
I just find that a little bit distracting,
but overall I am very impressed, and very saddened, by this piece of- This piece of art.
*laughter*
Well, Griffin, I- I appreciate your feedback and honesty.
Next time, I'll- I'll try and incorporate some of these ideas.
And with that, we have Render Two.
*Very dramatic music*
God. Oh, God.
*Laughter*
This is a very "Niko-esque" design.
he's got a lot of
*More laughter*
Yeah, this is a Niko render, for sure.
Are they jumping after him, or are they tossing him into hell? It's hard to tell.
This piece is titled "The Rising Crust," and it's about pizza, the common man, rising to the top, and overthrowing Papa John.
I think the composition is great. I think the lighting's great
Your message is that this is the pizza crust, the "rising crust." It leaves me wondering who the real tyrant is.
When- When one man with an army of pepperoni - monster - zombies topples another man.
I'm wondering who the pizza king is, really.
The difference between materials is a little more noticeable in this.
Even the- the pizza man.
He appears to have a little bit less drippy-ness to him.
But overall, I do think the composition is very nice.
It's a very kind of classical composition.
The light leads you through the page and allows you to explore with your eyes.
I'm a big fan of how much full-frontal nudity there is in this image. That's- That's working really strongly here.
I'll take that to heart
All righty. Why don't Clint, Griffin, and Jake provide their personal votes on what their favorite render was?
I gotta go with Niko's.
If I had to pick a background for my phone for a week, it'd be Niko's.
Sam's makes me feel something, and believe in something.
And for giving faith- Giving me that- that glimmer of hope in this trying time, my vote goes to Sam.
All righty. Well, the votes are in and, adding those votes to the Instagram contest we've been running,
the winner is...
Render Two: Niko's fall- "Rising Crust" "Rising Crust."
Thank you. Thank you everybody
Thank you to the voters. Thank you guys.
Thank you to pizza, pepperoni in particular.
I just want to thank all the pepperoni pizzas out there. Can't wait to make some more sick renders
Well, Sam, you're gonna have to uh, you're gonna have to download this on this on your phone
That was a wonderful render challenge and I'm happy to post this beautiful image. Let's see it there. Yeah. Wow, that looks pretty good
Phone background. Yeah, enjoy that laptop Nico. Yeah that laptop Nico. You know you guys I
did some heavy thinking
I'm gonna donate that laptop to court or digital because
corridor digital is much more need of a workstation laptop and
I'm using right now. That's right
Any time you want it belongs to all of us
Yeah, thanks for watching everybody and falsi at corridor digital on instagram he won't miss on the next one if you're following us now
I'll see I'm gonna go in the hyperspace. See y'all later good drive out of here. Bye